are you hoping to see coming up on the
season I think Nick needs to like the
good thing about Nick is he's always
gonna be Nick
no matter what happens good bad
indifferent whether you hate him or love
him like he's always gonna be himself I
think one thing that he could work on or
at least when he's dealing with 25 women
is maybe have a little bit more sympathy
or empathy and he will be even admit
like sometimes that's hard for him to do
because he's always like even a paradise
like remember if somebody didn't get a
rose you'd be like they'll be fine
they're fine it's like I know they're
gonna be fine but it's just it sucks to
see him go and so I think that was one
thing that Ben is just naturally so good
at is that like every time you saw a
girl leave the room that he didn't hit a
rose too you could just see it just it
crossed Ben for a couple seconds and you
did a great job of compartmentalizing
and realizing okay she's gone now I need
to focus on these women that are left
and I think that's hopefully one of the
things that Nick can work on is you know
just being able to realize that like you
know no matter if he ends up with this
woman or not like helm you know she came
out for him and he left some sort of
impression on him